conference I'm just talking with
developers and other interesting people
be usable from technology and pretty
cool ways and I'm sitting here right now
with Devendra could you tell me a little
bit and also the audience a little bit
about what you do here at Wolfram sort
of what your focus on is on sure let's
go thank you dizzy for this chance to
speak on Facebook it's a pleasure to
again last year and we I'm the manager
of calculus and algebra from I've been
here for a long time I joined 2001 so I
pretty much know everyone and every
aspect of the company's work but my main
concern is our users I'd like to help
them in every way and we are very wide
range of users we've got students
researchers teachers everyone likes to
use our products for their work and so
basically what I do is to combine a
little bit of development work some blog
post writing some online courses and try
and show how useful we can be to
everyone in the world literally we are
used quite a lot but we like people with
us even more and show that really the
world can be a different place if
software cool well so I know you focus
on calculus now run from language and I
don't know if that's changed a whole lot
since version 1 I know
like derivatives and limits and stuff
have been around in the product for a
while now but can you tell me a little
bit about some of the new features and
sure
so yes we've had derivatives and limits
and acting since version 1 essentially
and really speaking they've been pretty
solid from start but in the period
intervening things have changed people
requested new features and we have had
some gaps so in this release cycle for
version 12 we've actually kind of
revamped the whole of basic calculus so
in version 11.10 the derivative
functionality to make it do things like
nth derivative so you can find a
millionth derivative of a function quite
easily and then you can find
multivariate limits that's a staple
topic in advanced calculus and now as we
go up to version 12 we actually began
improving integrate that's the major
improvement for this release because
integrate is a very values function it's
it's really a piece of artificial
intelligence how it gets surging we
don't understand ourselves so anyone who
works on integrate is taking a huge huge
risk but we've taken at this time we
made the documentation much nicer so
people use calculus now will sense that
what we have is much more like a
textbook and really useful can you tell
me a little bit about specifically
asymptotic expansion I know that some of
the new stuff that's coming up and can
you tell me sort of what you would use
asymptotic expansion for and sort of why
you would want to use like asymptotic
and a great or asymptotic to solve some
of these things sure so the idea of an
asymptotic expansion is to try and give
an approximate formula which works
really well in a certain kind of regime
so for example if you want to find n
factorial for very large and it's a
1,000 factorial then there are very nice
asymptotic formula which work well for
large values but not so well for small
values all it's a prime number theorem
is another example or something
asymptotic so we have these new
functions asymptotically solve value
asymptotic integrate and now asymptotic
are sol value which actually you could
find simple formula which are very
powerful videos real certain point that
point could be 0 that point could be
infinity or whatever but they are much
simpler than the actual differential
equations and they are very very useful
so in fact a lot of technology today the
whole of aerodynamics is just asymptotic
expansions because you have a certain
boundary layer around your fluid and
then that creates all the motion in a
very organized way so we try and use
that notion of asymptotic expansions to
deliver useful formula so so I know I
imagine a lot of the audience's probably
familiar with expansions and in the way
of Taylor expansions our asymptotic
expansions it's more general than that
or Taylor expansions a kind of
asymptotic expansion but let me say
Taylor expansions are definitely the
most basic and important kind of product
expansion so if you know Taylor
expansions you know a lot of asymptotics
so I'm sure a lot of college students
know asymptotics they just haven't heard
the word but beyond that you might have
situations where things diverge where
things kind of blow up and then you need
asymptotics in the sense of divergent
formulae which are hard to control but
much more useful so for example there's
something called Airy function which is
very useful but which diverges so you
need an asymptotic formula
so basically asymptotics is a
generalization of Taylor series they
work really well like Taylor series but
one has to know how many terms to use
the strain theme of there is that let's
see if you've got five terms you might a
really good answer
now if you take ten terms meant with
really bad out so as a number of terms
increases the accuracy might actually go
down and that's why asymptotic is really
an art it's not a science
so do we have any functionality now that
allows you to create sort of formula is
asymptotic formulas from various exact
functions yes we do and so for example
if you give a version 12 a sequence a
few time of sequence it will guess a
kind of recurrence relation for that
sequence and then deliver in Nice
asymptotic formula and it will work
brilliantly when let's say n is 1000
where as being the actual calculation
might run your computer memory so we
have lots of these examples and they
basically let you make progress in let's
say doing compute algorithm study or you
want to do number theory on the common
Erik's all those areas now require
asymptotic expansion so yes we have lots
of that in the awesome
well speaking a little bit more broadly
with calculus here we have a calculus
MOOC now offer that Wolfram you can you
tell me a little bit about sort of what
the force entails
kind of whom the ideal audience would be
students or professional you know the
cactus mousse a MOOC came out over the
last one year I began recording probably
around eight months ago and there are 50
videos who were there and the video
start with something as simple as what
is calculus and then they go on slowly
to doing standard topics and calculus
but I think that this course is really
good for anyone from let's say I would
say middle school all the way up to
college or adulthood and in fact I am
watching this course with a 13 year old
right now to figure out how she follows
it it's going really well I get some
questions so I know where to improve but
I feel this course is designed for a
very broad audience
people should learn calculus if they can
and here's an opportunity for you to it
kind of free of charge a lot of work has
gone on we have got excellent training
on video teams which put a lot of effort
to this kind of course so the calculus
Coast begins with the basics and then
goes on rapidly all the way to cover
what we call AP Calculus a B in this
country that's a pretty challenging
course so by the time you finish you'll
have done quizzes you'll have done
problem sessions and exam and you'll be
ready to take on calculus either at
school or college where you want to
start so okay so it's free first of all
so that's great
but is it is it also sort of interactive
how are these students how would they be
learning calculus sure so when you watch
a video and actually you wanted to try
things so you can we give you a scratch
window where you can basically try all
the examples we book just as you do in
the video you can change the example you
can try examples of your own so what we
have really over there is a perfectly
interactive thing like a notebook kind
of interface but you can try what you
want to and improve your skills as you
go along but there's no fear there's no
exam there's no instructor tell you what
to do you work at your pace
enjoy yourself and we have done we can
give you a very beautiful certificate
and hopefully one day that will inspire
to become a really good mathematician
and you know break new ground can you
tell me maybe about some new upcoming
features sure so I mentioned two of the
monastic people who do calculus saw even
precalculus want us to tell them things
like when is the function continuous
when this is no they know brought a
break in the graph of function and we
have that comes very simple
functionality coming out very soon and
another area is what we call linear
algebra so linear algebra is the study
of linear equations and geometrical
things like planes and lines and linear
algebra is central to everything you
only learn machine learning you won't do
data science you want to do engineering
you want anything then then you also
Brown and calculus give you the
background for doing them so if you've
done calculus now and you work in linear
algebra and over the next one year we'll
have lots of stuff to show you which
relates to linear algebra and hopefully
if your lineage burns calculus done you
can
Kurian data science or whatever like
awesome well thanks devinder for taking
the time to talk with me anyway um
thanks for watching this live stream
anyway um do you have any final words
for the audience yes uh I just want to
say that what we have over from language
is a wonderful way to learn mathematics
and application not just what I do but
omit processing neural networks
statistics and if you can make use of
that to somehow blend with your own
studies and get yourself a nice career
we'd be thrilled we are here to help you
and we always with you so good luck and
what you do and that really is my
message to the audience today awesome
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]